also breaking tonight police are  investigating an officer-involved  shooting near Las Vegas Boulevard and  pemble this happened around 7 30 tonight  officials say a suspect is in custody  and to avoid the area as that  investigation continues officers say  this started as a normal traffic stop  I was attempted to make a person stop on  that subject when he produced a firearm  the officers fired at the suspect the  suspect was struck was transported to a  local hospital where he's currently  receiving medical treatment  this marks the ninth officer-involved  shooting in Metro's jurisdiction so far  this year all we know of this incident  as of right now you can stay with us of  course on air and online as we continue  to get updates